justement les mais plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont manifesté hier pour dire
non à ce qu'ils estiment être une
ingérence turquie l'accusant kara
d'envoyer des armes et des mercenaires
ou forces du gouvernement d'union
nationale reconnue par l'onu
les manifestants ont multiplié les
messages virulents à l'égard de ce chef
du gouvernement face à roche et du
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
écoutez je dis au peuple turc que vous
avez détruit vos intérêts en libye que
vos relations avec la libye ont pris fin
et que votre réputation a été ternie
la réputation des turcs étaient bonnes
ici nous avons des bâtiments et des
entreprises turques nous avons des
restaurants turc des travailleurs turcs
mais maintenant votre image a été
détruite par erdogan car c'est un sale
membres des frères musulmans un sale
chien et il n'a rien à voir avec notre
pays
le peuple libyen est un peuple libre et
le peuple libyen continue à suivre le
chemin de la marche des martyrs et nous
en tant qu'institution de la société
civile et peuple libyen libre sommes
conscients et connaît son ampleur de la
conspiration que le monde mène contre
nous mais si dieu le veut nous allons
étonné ce monde par notre ténacité
historique
nous sommes contre la conquête turque et
contre le gouvernement de concorde
nationale à tripoli et si dieu le veut
nous sommes victorieux grâce à la
vigueur de notre jeunesse
que dieu le préserve et les protège